you have a child missing everything come
in your man why didn't I hug him before
he left they didn't even give me the
opportunity to set back Jackson
Mississippi Police accidentally struck
and killed this woman's son with their
Cruiser instead of telling her they hid
the body from her and buried it
themselves better seen Wade's son Dexter
went missing in March she reported The
Disappearance of the police days later
but they claimed not to have any
information about him they were straight
up lying in fact a police cruiser struck
and killed Dexter just 1 hour after he
left his mother's home but instead of
informing betterin about her son's death
they let his body sit for months in the
County morg eventually cops buried him
on the grounds of a nearby penal Farm
making the story even more tragic this
isn't the first family member betterin
has lost to police violence her
62-year-old brother was killed in 2019
when police body slammed him as of
November 2023 Jackson Police have not
responded to questions about the
circumstances of Dexter Wade's killing